3 2 1 aux tic tic tic
bonjour monsieur
merci eh ben ça va c'était plaisir
peut-être ce n'était pas nécessaire
autant de gras si je peux me permettre
le tirage a eu lieu le 4 décembre à
cette date le joueur ignore qu'il a
touché le jackpot il est en déplacement
à l'étranger dans sa sacoche de voyage
il y à son ticket
la suite de l'histoire il l'a raconté à
la française des jeux j'ai garé ma
sacoche au restaurant durant mon séjour
j'ai dû envoyer un taxi pour la
récupérer à l'époque je ne savais pas
que mon reçu des gagnants jamais je
n'aurais imaginé que ma sacoche
contenait 30 millions d'euros allez au
beau temps est au rendez vous du côté de
serre chevalier et le père noël a pu en
profiter c'est ce qu'on appelle du
windsurf la famille du gagnant n'est
toujours pas au courant il annoncera la
bonne nouvelle à noël avant de les
emmener en voyage et tant qu'à faire à
son retour il compte même s'offrir une
maison et les familles de riches quoi
voilà et et on sait quelle famille de
rentiers enfin c'est pas non plus une
majorité en france mais ça existe et
s'il faut plus d'inégalités je resterai
plus d'inégalités justement pour le
d'égalité d'égalité d'équité
et des français a au moment d'héritage
si vous gagnez un vélo que voulez vous
en faire alors j'aimerais partir au
machu picchu avec une amie et ont réussi
à faire ma cuisine voilà plus de vingt
ans donc j'aimerais bien la roue faire
la cuisine d'accord je ne sais pas la
copine met en avant ça c'est du pur
monde où tout bas grosse surprise pour
les employés d'une société espagnole de
vente et location de voiture ils ont été
réunis dans le stade du club de majorque
où chacun a reçu un billet de tombola la
bonne nouvelle c'est qu'ils sont tous
gagnants
après une année commerciale historique
les 450 employés vont se partager un
million d'euros
une prime de noël exceptionnel répartis
selon leur ancienneté 300 euros pour les
nouveaux arrivés et 10000 pour les plus
anciens alors c'est la dernière
trouvaille de la république en marche
pour vanter le bilan de l'année mâcon
c15 antisèches pour préparer les
militants au débat en famille alors
l'idée c'est votre beau-frère vous
interpelle votre oncle qu'ils
interrogent après un long récit votre
nièce bref une famille aux aguets avoir
chauffé à blanc qui attend le maquereau
nist au tournant prenons un exemple la
case oh j'ai l'impression que tout
augmente sauf mon salaire et bien la
réponse qui vous est proposée par la
république en marche home et usep tata
avec la revalorisation du travail les
primes et les aides pour les plus
modestes depuis cinquante notre pouvoir
d'achat augmenter de 8% ce n'est pas un
gouvernement qu'ils disent et l'insee
[Musique]
et je le savais c'était riche autre
question en quelle insécurité il faut
mettre plus de policiers dans la rue
réponses proposées nous avons donné au
ministère de l'intérieur les moyens de
leurs ambitions de l'entente son budget
de 7 milliards d'euros cela a permis de
recruter les dix mille policiers et
gendarmes promis en 2010 cette voie là
je vous demanderais d'avoir beaucoup de
vigilance pendant ces fêtes alors la
vigilance c'est évidemment de continuer
à avoir nos gestes barrière contre le
virus dès qu'il ya des symptômes nous
isoler et nous tester c'est même si vous
êtes vacciné de vous tester vous même ou
d'aller vous faire tester pour être sûr
que vous n'êtes pas porteurs du virus
avant de retrouver leurs proches en
particulier quand ils sont plus âgés
pour beaucoup noël dépend du résultat de
ce test emmanuel a choisi de rester
positif quoi qu'il arrive je passerai
avec ma copine on fait la fête à la
maison voilà dans cette pharmacie c'est
l'effervescence
les demandes de tests explose et pour
les pcr il faut apprendre à dire non à
wayne en occultant ce soit le relais à
l'europe dont toutes les langues bah moi
je verrais plutôt psycho là comme ma
mère
très bien je crois que c'est la première
fois de ma vie que je vois une enfant de
11 ans qui me dit j'aimerais être
psychologue ksb dans ce métier
aide sociale à etc les gens et des les
gens allaient mieux oui si c'est ce que
tu veux faire ça c'est une nouvelle
attention j'ai grandi dans les années
soixante dix où je n'ai jamais vu mon
père s'arrêter de travailler parce qu'il
avait la grippe ou de la fièvre il
bossait aujourd'hui si vous allez
travailler avec la grippe vous êtes un
criminel donc évidemment c'est celle
c'est-à-dire chagny terre ont changé oui
c'est tout ce que je constate donc dans
le temps ce monde a changé dans le temps
et se couchait que pour mourir bon
maintenant effectivement première fois
qu'on se rencontre si vous mentez vous
allez en enfer exactement il croyait pas
l'enfer les frais chez pascal
on est on est en berne il faut le dire
clairement et regardez comme c'est beau
damien et ils ont ils ont faim attendez
je me tenais un petit bout
non vous ne rêvez pas il semblerait que
le père noël est un peu d'avancé cette
année
mais pour les cadeaux il faudra encore
un peu patienter
il n'a que des bonbons à offrir pour
l'instant c'est trop cool c'est que si
j'avais vu un père noël tu volais l
aiguille bon bon bon gène et frédéric
owni bas c'est parti on va rejoindre le
père noël tu as bien là et on va porter
vos questions on va prévenir de
téléspectateurs que la mère noël et en
blanc cette année si vous voyez passer
je vous voyez c'est l'année de l onu sur
les remercie pour cette très belle ses
très belles images dis-toi claudine vous
avez changé de coiffure depuis le
dernier passage je vous reconnais pas
malheureusement depuis votre mac équipés
de moi
je ne sais pas ça de coded s'il vous
plaît de me
pas dit ça du tout je reconnaissais pas
assez terrible et alors regardez qui
j'ai croisé chez le coiffeur pourquoi on
vient au dernier moment mar bat un peu
comme tout le monde les derniers cadeaux
la dernière coupe on est à moins de deux
jours du réveillon donc et pas le choix
et finalement j'ai de la chance j'ai
profité d'un trou dans le planning et
moi aussi je serai bien coiffé pour noël
si on finissait cette partie par une
histoire de colomb
[Musique]
est la veille du repas de noël
vaut mieux se préparer tuyau
d'évacuation
[Rires]